ready for some bayflation I know
the stadium and a country's economy
here's why all right I sold it before I
actually broke down the story here we go
Superstars Renaissance tour is being
blamed for raising Sweden's inflation
rate by about two tenths of a percentage
point last month here's what yeah here's
what an economist says uh Beyonce fans
flock the Stockholm and sent hotel
prices soaring once she launched her
tour there on May 10th and 11 he says
that was enough to affect inflation
Nationwide look hotel rooms were booked
40 miles outside of the steel no
absolutely yeah can move markets she's
like Warren Buffett no absolutely I know
multiple people who've gone to Europe
just to see our concert I mean our very
own executive producer Shauna Thomas
went to Scotland to see Beyonce I mean
how about that yeah Bay flation